let's watch the next one
stop shaming and skinny shaming are the
same actually no they're not fat people
are denied jobs proper Medical Care
Health Insurance they're paid less they
don't have equal access to clothing
travel many public spaces even the body
mass index the way that it discriminates
against women especially women of color
it was created for and based around
white men like fat phobia is literally
rooted in anti-blackness it's rooted in
racism and sexism skinny shaming is not
how many times have you seen marketing
campaigns that are labeled get fat quick
finally add those stubborn 30 pounds
show me where all the weight gain
Industries are show me all the damaging
messages that say that skinny equals
unworthy life or skinny equals ugly when
is the last time that you've been
penalized financially when an aircraft
seed had to be accommodated to your
smaller body my favorite part of this
clip is is her list of oppressions and
persecutions that fat people face she
says fat people don't have equal access
to clothing which is an interesting way
of putting it so if I Gorge myself
during Thanksgiving and put on five
pounds in one weekend I can then
complain that I don't have equal access
to my own pants anymore